the next story we have check this out
city of oakland mayor is branded racist
for giving families of color 500
a month if they earn under 59 000 with
no rules on how they spend it
but offering poor white families nothing
oakland mayor libby chef announced the
race-based program to give families of
color 500
monthly checks half of the 500 grants
will be to families earning under 30 000
in the predominantly bipark east oakland
area now a couple important things to
point out
for one it's privately funded okay so
fine if somebody
has a million dollars and they say i'm
only going to give it to people i want
to give it to well welcome to private
exchange of wealth that's
okay there you go the city is
implementing this though so i have
questions about the legality even if it
is privately funded
but the other thing is they say by poc
you know what that means
uh i'm gonna guess correct me if i'm
wrong black and indigenous people of
color
yes and do you know what do you know
what there's two minority groups missing
from that bipod
uh jewish canadians oh all right well i
guess if you want to get really
technical there's a lot of people
missing from my pocket
asians yeah latinos but
asians have been elevated asian people
by paca yeah
[Laughter]
so look man i wouldn't qualify for
something like this
right and you have people in this
country who are not even white who would
not qualify for something like this
this is where things start to getting
start getting twisted they talk about
reparations this ain't reparations this
is literally being like
just not for you white person so you you
know you told a story about how you move
here and you're you know you're
would you consider yourself poor when i
moved here yeah yeah i i
was like you don't qualify for any help
sorry yeah i know because of your race
okay we've judged you we know well that
isn't that racist
sir quite literally is the definition of
yes racist okay so can
can you fix it and can i then get
reparations because i didn't get
reparations
is that what we're gonna do is it gonna
be another 50 years and then we're like
all of these programs and all this money
that was spent was racist therefore
reparations for white people
yeah i think we we knew this was coming
in this country
you knew this right i knew this look you
need to understand
my family was experiencing all of this
critical race theory stuff when i was a
little kid
coming from a mixed race family i think
there's a lot of white suburban
you know and like uh there's a lot of
white people who don't realize
this stuff has been happening for a
really really long time right and
it was in our faces you know what i mean
so uh look my dad's white and there were
there was anti-white sentiment with
affirmative action and things like that
in chicago
and so he would get told that he was
wealthy and privileged for being white
meanwhile
he's in a mixed-race relationship which
is extremely rare in this country
oh by the way that's a sign of racism i
don't know if you caught uh bill burr
the fact that he's married that's right
woman make something nice now apparently
i didn't know
uh siraj hajime said that guy was a
troll and yes but there are many people
who have already said that i was at uw
in seattle
and one of these woke guys was arguing
to me that mixed race relationships
particularly with asians especially with
asians was a sign of you know
fascism or whatever because you know
germany loved the japanese
and i was like you're a [ __ ] yeah just
i just don't even where to begin
but uh you know growing up and having my
family be
like i guess i guess we could say lower
middle class but then we ultimately
ended up losing our home
to a bankruptcy it's really interesting
to be in a family where it's like
you know some sometimes our fridge is
going to be empty or we're eating like
steaks from dominic's that are like
particularly cheap
and my family does the best that it can
but we're by no means rich
and then you know my dad gets told he's
not qualified for a promotion or things
like that because he's the wrong race
so you mean to tell me that we have the
civil rights fight
loving v virginia to make it legal for
inter to ban miscegenation laws right it
was actually illegal before 1967 in many
states
to cohabitate with someone of a
different race isn't that crazy wow
1967. yeah it's not even that long ago
man no i
think i feel like sodomy was legal in
more states right probably
yeah and so you actually had this period
where like my
my mom and my mom's side of the family
are growing up literally at a time when
they had to flee different states
because it was
quite literally illegal yeah well
congratulations civil rights uh protests
worked
and now here i am and now i'm told
depending on my ideology i don't fit in
i don't qualify for their special
programs and i try to explain to people
listen
i'm the last person in the world who's
going to complain about my identity and
be like i demand this because i'm
marginalized for this reason
but i will point out your hypocrisy and
your short-sightedness
what these people don't realize when
they talk about the by the black
indigenous people of color
communities the indigenous community has
a community
the black community has a community the
latinos have a community the asians have
a community
there's no like mixed race meeting
groups
where you share your common cultures in
fact koreans
are extremely racist and they're not
forgiving
so you grow up in this environment where
the only thing you actually have that
that you you
you know you find yourself surrounded by
is americans i grew up in an area where
you know
people of all different races all
americans so there was no issue with
race
now we're entering this world where
they're claiming they're the champions
against racism
and they're quite literally making it
worse for everybody especially the ones
that the civil rights movement fought to
help and it's amazing most of the people
that
are against racism are also
anti-american
definitely and when you when you say
that there's this unity between people
that just
no matter what race they are hanging
american flags outside their home
you're just like oh everybody's going to
get along here no matter what's
happening
because they believe in the country the
thought came into my head
literally this morning and we haven't
heard it for
years because it didn't exist during
trump's presidency
remember the old love it or leave it
quote that people used to say all the
well you love it or you leave it and
it's like
that is so far gone now because the
country's gone through such
turmoil and separation it's inevitably
gonna change there's no going back
to that life liberty pursuit of
happiness love it or leave it i don't
think so
i think that he was the closest thing
that they were gonna get but
trump's egoism probably kept us from
that
uh but i don't think it's gonna happen
it's not gonna happen under this
presidency
i mean joe biden's awful for a lot of
reasons and i think
donald trump was an imper i call him the
imperfect avatar of the
of the national populist rage that they
were feeling the establishment was a
crooked
is the establishment politicians it are
crooked corrupt crony politicians we've
done it for a long time
we saw the the occupy protests you know
now almost 10 years ago people in this
country were fed up with the revolving
door policies
some guy works for halliburton and also
he's the vice president
we knew how the game was being played
and we snapped and said enough
and you had a split you had left
populists who are like we need social
programs and welfare and socialist
policy and then you had the right
laissez-faire more capitalist things
like that
some many moderates and then you end up
with
donald trump and he was the one strong
enough to smash the door down
unfortunately he's imperfect maybe ron
desantis in 2024 will
will be much better and more tactful and
better embody
that anger from you know many of the
american nationalist types
bernie sanders came out recently and
denounced the the permanent suspension
of donald trump from the social media
platforms that's a good sign
yeah and i'm hoping that we can we can
find certain things
to agree on because the the you know the
trump supporters i think recognize this
to a certain degree
they have more in common with bernie
sanders supporters and these
progressives than they do with the
democratic establishment
sure the problem is many of these
progressives will vote for a
for a corporate democrat before they
ever imagine voting for
a right-wing populist because they think
they're fascists that's what that
that's the bear that's got to be broken
down where it's like look man
my my policy positions my ideals i took
the political compass test
i'm even further left than i realized in
the political competence it was crazy
yeah because i'm like tax the rich and
all stuff and i'm like how about this
how about we tax the hollywood rich is
that something conservatives would agree
with i think they probably would i think
it's a good
it's a fun idea for when you run for
office i'm not going to try to
never no way come on no you know i i
will you know you can kill a whole bunch
of
old people then you can just go flirt
with women and nobody cares
touch your face hey i'm italian
whoopsie i'm italian
is that racist or are we allowed to talk
about italians because talk about who
you could just put the trouble to me i
just showed up here you could just say i
just dropped into your house
i think it's like it's almost like
hillary clinton and donald trump were
extreme versions of themselves or the
ideas of what they represented
like trump represented the anger from
right-wing populists and the america
first types the people who want this
country
to to actually use its tax dollars to
support this country
then you get trump trump is um is like
he's almost
america incarnate he's a loud arrogant
boisterous capitalist yes entrepreneur
so america like what what did obama say
you know in his
in college the american dream is to be
donald trump hillary clinton
was like it's really amazing if you were
to if on a scale of 1 to 1
to 10 of representations of things
you know in this country donald trump is
cranked up to 11
yeah in terms of like how much he
embodies this kind of american
exceptionalism
president goes to 11. right and hillary
clinton
when you want to embody corrupt
corporate crony politics
she was cranked up to 11 as well yeah
and trump barely won that one
joe biden they cranked down a little bit
and then i guess you know that was
enough for him
i don't think he knows what he's doing
and i think but
hold on hold on i'm sorry yeah when you
say i don't think he knows what he's
doing
do you mean to say like as president or
just at any given moment at any given
moment tim
he doesn't know where he's standing he
has no idea what's going on
him walking up the plane steps was just
so funny
uh he has no idea he he's a puppet
for that party and they it would have
been awesome
to see bernie sanders run against trump
i i think that they
they could have used that extremism
bernie i i don't i don't know if bernie
would win now because of critical race
theory
but i think bernie would have won in
2016 hands down yeah nine million people
switched
from voting for obama in 2012 to voting
for trump i like the notion
of desantis because when you're an
immigrant
and you move here you embrace american
ideals
although somewhat antiquated so our
version of america was when reagan was
president when i would watch tv and
you'd watch the news and i was in my
early teens and you're like that's where
i want to live
i want to live where you can say trickle
down economics that's where i want to
live
and there was this beauty of it and
scarface was around that time and there
was just this
notion of the american dream and that's
what we kicked the doors down to have we
didn't
want to kick the doors down and be like
no no no you're white get to the back of
the line
and i've heard it numerous i was up for
a comedy central thing
first year they go you're perfect but we
got enough white guys second year
no really oh how long ago really uh i
i did ari shafir's show and it was
called this is not happening
so this is maybe four years ago and now
comedy central
is the wokest you can get you remember
broad city kind of trailed them off
and now they're just doing bar shows
with 20 people in
horrible woke comedy but they told me i
had this story
where i i'm gonna say it as clean as
possible because i don't want you to get
in trouble
uh i pleasured myself in front of two
men
for 150 and at climax
the man said i want it on me but i
didn't want to go over there because
that was too
uh femme for me so i threw it at him and
that was
that's the whole bit it's a 15-minute
story
it's brilliant it's brilliant
you can't tell it clean it's available
on comedycentral.com you can watch it
it's like
a hot chocolate story it's a real story
i was a stripper for like a summer and a
half
and uh and this story was perfect for
this thing it was this long-form
storytelling show
about stuff that you can't believe
happened this is not happening then
second year i submitted
and ari's a friend of mine he goes
you're great but they really need
uh women of color they're looking for so
they would down that happened to me
advice
yeah and then fusion and then year three
he goes you came really close but they
already had enough famous work and then
i was at a mets game and someone called
i guess someone dropped out they're like
can you be in la saturday and shoot this
and i go yeah but i i've had it happen
to my face where because of the color of
your skin
not the content of your character you're
denied something and the problem is
what is it 66 to 70 of the country is
white
is it yeah that'll be significantly less
in what 20 years
it will be i think in 20 years it'll be
some something like in the 50s like by
2050
it's going to be you know when like
white people become a minority they'll
still be the plurality
and then we get reparations you know
i i think my issue with it is i actually
like the idea of representation
you know you know i talk about this
quite a bit when i can't remember what
happened uh
some marvel movie was coming out i think
it was black panther when black panther
came out
i saw it four times and did you like it
i did not want it really no
oh you didn't see it no i thought yeah i
thought it was great is it great yeah
there's a there's a line where t'challa
the king of wakanda goes we cannot allow
immigrants into our country because
they'll bring their problems with us
and i was like whoa whoa that's like
super trumpian yeah it's in the movie we
must build a wall
they have a wall they literally have a
wall that keeps everyone out of their
country okay right did they say this we
will make wakanda great again that
they totally said that they didn't need
to because it was already great did you
say this
oh look at you sleepy joe did he say
that at any point
okay but the the so but i was commenting
on the movie and i was like listen
they did iron man white dude they did
thor white dude captain america white
dude i got no issue with the color of
these guys's skin
right but i do recognize that sooner or
later it's gonna be a movie it's not a
white dude you know what i mean like
they got to make movies for everybody in
this country that people can enjoy and
they do it right
when they don't beat you over with the
ideology and just show
regular people doing regular things
right right but now they're beating us
over the head with you right right right
i think
i can't remember who was who was here
and we were talking about this saying
that like
you know uh for every show you're
allowed like
one teaspoon of like social justice or
like
ideology so you're watching a movie it's
a horror movie there's like a vampire is
attacking people and then they
make like a passive comment about
redlining in urban environments or
whatever
yeah as they do oh i just ate some red
pilled blood
the vampire like goes to a poor
community and they make a reference yeah
the point is
if you're watching a movie and they make
a social commentary
a little bit is fine and we recognize
and go i see
but now what we're getting is literally
the whole movie itself is just a social
commentary so there's no story there's
no plot it's trash
get woke go bro exactly i i thought uh
i thought black panther was actually
good there was a lot of social
commentary in it but i thought it was
good because
t'challa was like trump
i mean not in the sense of his attitude
i mean chitalo and
his and his physique t'challa was super
ripped
you know
but like to see the argument where
they're talking about how these other
african nations are doing really really
bad
yeah and wakanda is doing really well
t'challa is literally like if we let in
immigrants they bring their problems
with
with them and i'm like he's supposed to
be the hero for these leftists
he's the the black representation that
they were cheering for and here he is
saying something
that should offend them but they cheered
for it because the ideology was more
important to them
than what he was actually saying i
thought it was i thought it was actually
really well written is that because the
power corrupts
that he starts out with these great
intentions and then you get he does open
up in the end
yeah but he he then goes to one of the
but i love this
seriously you guys got to watch this
because here he is
in sub-saharan africa in wakanda and
they have this gigantic wall it's an
invisible barrier that not only
stops people from getting into their
country but or into their
capital city i suppose whatever it is
but they also can't even see it
okay erase it they don't want anybody
they're super xenophobic
he says that line we can't let people in
they'll bring their problems with us
at the end of the movie when he finally
decides decides to open the country
does he go and help these other
sub-saharan african countries
no he goes to oakland he goes to the
wealthiest country on the planet
and he goes to one of their wealthiest
states and he goes to one of the biggest
cities
he's got his problems and he gives
resources to the people there
i'm like that's a profound statement
when remember when they accuse donald
trump of saying something like we don't
want people from these you know ish
whole countries yeah
we want them from norway or whatever
that's literally what they had to child
to do
yeah instead of being like okay we're
finally going to open up let's get
people from you know the
zimbabwe and and south africa to come to
our country he goes to oakland
he goes to the country he goes to the
united states where there's prosperity
and wealth
he was still in the end extremely
classist
it's remarkable to see that especially
remarkable to see how
they don't like these woke people don't
recognize exactly what was wrong with
what t'challa was doing
yeah based on their own ideology let me
ask you this if
the actions trump took
were done by a black president
would it have had the same blowback
for the left for the country as a whole
and for the left
the problem with that question is is he
a black republican or a black democrat
because you know if he's a black
republican the black community is going
to call him a certain word
well do it all the time all the woke
people all of them the entire
it's not this is what's really
fascinating would it does it confuse the
woke people
because they want to have those thoughts
and say oh this guy's uh
this guy's a xenophobe this guy's a
bigot oh but he's black
oh okay is that gonna change the
argument
and that's uh a kind of it's a really
interesting thing
t'challa and wakanda from black panther
had a lot of trumpian policies
and they loved it not only that check
this out the movie
shows that in wakanda you become the
supreme autocrat of the country through
patriarchal
ritual combat that's their political
process
people loved it yeah so even though you
have a guy who you you should be
despising based on what you
purport to support they loved it
if you took a democrat a white old man
joe biden they'd vote for him and they'd
claim that he wasn't racist even though
he's got decades of racist history
passing all these laws that are like
criticized for being racist not anymore
joe biden's the only president that's on
camera saying the n-word twice
donald trump won a bunch of awards first
did he win like a couple awards for
civil rights i know he did he's in these
photos he was like parks
he's the first person to hire a woman to
like build a skyscraper
and now he's you know they say racist
sexist anti-gay donald trump go away
it's like donald trump is the first
president in american history to support
gay marriage before becoming president
yeah he unfurled a rainbow flag like a
republican convention or whatever
and got the rnc to clap and cheer for
the lgbtq community
like that was trump but they call him a
bigot barack obama
comes in blows up kids in the middle
east american citizens
they disappear gone they don't care
obama can do what he wants because he's
a democrat
joe biden will get elected and they'll
sing his praises because he's a democrat
when they complain the republican party
is the party of white men
the rnc had several black people speak
what did the left say
they didn't praise the republicans for
finally doing the right thing and trying
to diversify
they said tokens yeah an extremely
racist comment about legitimate
individuals with good policies and good
ideas
that are worthy of argument accomplished
individuals and that
that's why those people make me sick
because they're more racist
than the other side oh these these great
black
highly intellectual politicians that are
well spoken have
great policies formulated for their
areas they're only talking because you
need them
up there they're tokens that's exactly
what they say
it's so hypocritical and our job is to
call out that hypocrisy but when you do
then you're the race thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you